Hi I'm Michelle from Lab Muffin Beauty
Science! Today we're going to be talking
about collagen supplements. If you're into
beauty and skin care you may have
seen collagen supplements around. And
you'll have seen claims like how taking
collagen will smooth wrinkles, boost
firmness and make your skin more elastic.
But do they really work? Since I have a
PhD in medicinal chemistry I needed to
check out the evidence for myself. Here's
what I found.
Collagen is a protein which means it's
long chain of amino acids chemically
joined together.
Collagen is an incredibly important
protein that's part of what's called the
extracellular matrix. This holds the
cells in your body together. It's also
found in bones, tendons and tissue. In
your skin, collagen lives in the lower
layer called the dermis. It's important
for giving your skin structure and
elasticity, which translates to bouncy
skin. As you get older your body produces
less collagen. It's estimated that skin
collagen drops by about 1% per year.
There's also a change in the types of
collagen in your skin so you end up with
thin wrinkly skin that's more prone to
damage. Damage from the environment can
also destroy collagen. Sun exposure and
smoking are especially harmful.
That's why sun-damaged skin looks older
and sunscreen is so important.
So logically eating collagen could
give your body the building blocks to
make more collagen. Unfortunately you
have very little control over what your
body does with the things you eat. Eating
plants doesn't mean we end up green and
able to photosynthesize and make food
from sunshine. Eating a mirrorball won't
make you glittery no matter how much you
want to shine.
Like I mentioned,
collagen is a protein made up of lots of
amino acids joined together. In your
stomach and small intestine you have
enzymes that will break up proteins like
collagen into smaller fragments so you
can absorb them into your body. So most
of the time when you eat a protein it
will get broken up and your body won't
be able to tell which protein you've
eaten. But collagen has a special amino
acid in it: hydroxyproline. In humans
hydroxyproline is only found in collagen.
So when you eat collagen you'll end up
with hydroxyproline in your blood, so
your body can tell you've eaten collagen.
But does this do anything?
There have been a bunch of studies where
collagen supplements improve skin in
mice and rats and even pigs. It's also
been found that after eating a collagen
supplement human volunteers have
fragments of broken-down collagen called
prolyl-hydroxyproline in their blood. In
vitro, prolyl-hydroxyproline fragments were
found to make human skin cells grow
faster and produce more hyaluronic acid,
another component of the dermis.
Hyaluronic acid keeps the water content
in your skin high which is also
important for bouncy unwrinkled skin. But
the study doesn't tell us anything about
whether the fragments get from the blood
to the skin in high enough
concentrations to actually do anything,
which is sort of absolutely crucial to
whether or not collagen supplements work.
So does it work in actual people?
Here's what the clinical trials have
found so far. In one study by a
supplement company volunteers took 5
grams of hydrolyzed collagen made from
fish cartilage every day along with
other vitamins and minerals. After 60
days, dryness, wrinkles and the depth of
the nasolabial fold
(that's the groove between your nose and
cheek) improved, and after 12 weeks
collagen density and skin firmness also
improved. But most parts of the trial
didn't use a placebo control so it isn't
as reliable, and of course there's the
bias issue. In another study volunteers
took either a daily supplement
containing 2.5 grams of
collagen peptide or a placebo for eight
weeks. There were improvements in eye
wrinkles as well as procollagen and
elastin content of the dermis. The trial
was run independently by a university.
The same supplement also improved skin
elasticity four weeks after the
volunteers stopped taking the supplement.
10 grams of a daily collagen peptide
supplement was found to improve skin
hydration after eight weeks, and
increased density and decreased
fragmentation of collagen in the dermis
after four weeks, according to placebo
controlled trials run by the manufacturer.
So right now you're probably thinking
that we should all immediately run out
and eat all of the collagen supplements.
But before you spend all your money I
have to burst your bubble a little bit
with some inconvenient facts. One of the
big issues with supplement studies is
that they often use supplements that
contain ingredients other than collagen
as well, so you can't say for sure that
it's collagen having the effect and not
the other ingredients. For the non
placebo controlled trials it could also
be something else entirely causing the
change. For collagen it's particularly
tricky because there are at least 28
types of collagen. Collagen is also made
up of thousands of amino acids. Most
studies use collagen that's been
hydrolyzed or broken up, but as you can
imagine with a chain that's thousands of
amino acids long, you can break it up
into different lengths. So a supplement
with collagen that's a thousand amino
acids long might not have the same
effect as one that uses fragments that
are 100 amino acids long or 50 amino
acids long or 10 amino acids long. So
even if a study finds a beneficial
effect with one collagen supplement it
doesn't mean that a different collagen
supplement will also work. If that's not
enough another issue is that a lot of
these studies are done by companies who
sell the supplements so there's an
obvious conflict of interest. It's
unlikely that they'll publish data that
show that there isn't any effect, and
it's likely that they have massaged the
results to look as good as possible.
Here's the verdict: collagen supplements
are pretty promising and could
potentially work, but the evidence is far
from solid. Only a few collagen
supplements have gotten good results in
studies and collagen supplements can be
very different. And most of these studies
were run by the companies that sell the
collagen supplements, so they're likely
to be biased. The results also don't
really find that collagen supplements
actually increase collagen and not just
improve your skin through other methods
like increasing hyaluronic acid,
or just indirectly changing your diet.
For example if you drink more collagen
based supplements maybe it makes you eat
less sugar because you're full from the
water, and it's actually the lower sugar
that improves your skin. If you have the
budget there isn't much harm in trying
collagen supplements as long as you
don't have an allergy, but if you want
the best bang for your buck I'd
recommend trying more proven ways of
protecting and increasing your collagen
first.
Preventing collagen from being destroyed
in the first place is much easier and
more effective than trying to repair
your skin later, so make sure you wear a
high UVA protection sunscreen daily. One
study found that collagen gets damaged
with about one-tenth of the UV that
causes a sunburn,
so not burning doesn't mean your skin
isn't being damaged. Vitamin C is also
great as an antioxidant for soaking up
free radicals that cause sun damage and
it can also increase collagen as well.
Vitamin A derivatives known as retinoids
are the gold standard for increasing
collagen in your skin, particularly
tretinoin. Glycolic acid has been found
to increase collagen in some studies as
well. If you want to get more hardcore,
chemical peels can increase collagen. So
can laser and IPL light treatments. If
you want to go super basic you should
make sure that your skin is adequately
hydrated. Dehydrated skin is a really
common cause of tired looking skin and
it's very easy to fix. Look for serums
and moisturizers with humectant
ingredients that help your skin hold
onto water, like glycerin and hyaluronic
acid to plump up skin and hide wrinkles.
That's all from me about collagen
supplements. I'm sure there'll be more
research soon on collagen that tells
us more about whether or not it actually
works. If you like my video I'd love it
if you could subscribe to my channel! You
can also follow me on Instagram and
Facebook for more beauty-based science tips (oops)
You can also check out my blog for tons
and tons of beauty science. See you next
time!